.
>> Bret: JACQUI HEINRICH LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN, THANK YOU.
>> I WOULDN'T CALL THAT A TAX
BUT IT WOULD HELP GET AT CAPITAL
GAINS WHICH ARE LARGE PART OF
THE INCOMES OF THE WEALTHIEST
INDIVIDUALS AND RIGHT ESTATE
TAXATION.
>> Bret: TREASURY SECRETARY
JANET YELLEN TALKING ABOUT NEW
PROPOSAL FOR THE PAY-FOR FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT AND WHAT'S
BEING DEBATED ON CAPITOL HILL
WITH UTAH REPUBLICAN SENATOR
FORMER REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINEE MITT ROMNEY.
SENATOR, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANKS BRET, GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU.
>> Bret: FIRST OF ALL, BEFORE WE
GETTED INTO THE NITTY GRITTY AND
DETAILS HERE.
THERE IS OPTIMISM BEING
PROJECTED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THESE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION TONIGHT AT THIS
TIME.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO GET
SOMETHING DONE FOR THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE IS KIND OF CIRCLING
THE DRAIN WITH THE ELECTORATE IN
THE COUNTRY.
AS A RESULT THEY ARE WILLING TO
DO ALMOST ANYTHING, I THINK.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE LEGISLATION
PASS.
BUT THE REAL PROBLEM IS THE
LEGISLATION IS NOT POPULAR WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS PEOPLE HAVE.
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
INFLATION, THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT EMPTY SHELVES.
AND THIS LEGISLATION MAKES
THINGS WORSE NOT BETTER.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
NEW PAID FOR STRUCTURE.
IT'S A PROPOSAL TO GO AFTER
UNREALIZED CAPITAL GAINS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE CALLING IT
WEALTH TAX ON 700 BILLIONAIRES.
WHY IN YOUR OPINION DOES THIS
NOT WORK?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT'S NOT A GOOD
IDEA TO TELL BILLIONAIRES DON'T
COME TO AMERICA, DON'T START
YOUR BUSINESS HERE TO TELL THE
STEVE JOBS AND THE BILL GAETZ
AND PEOPLE LIKE THAT THIS ISN'T
THE PLACE TO GROW YOUR BUSINESS
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
TAX PEOPLE NOT WITH THEY SELL
SOMETHING JUST WHEN THEY OOWN IT
AND THE VALUE GOES UP.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THE PEOPLE
MULTIBILLIONAIRES ARE LOOK AND
SAY I DON'T WANT TO INVESTIGATE
IN THE STOCK MARKET BECAUSE IF
THAT GOES UP, I AM GOING TO GET
TAXED.
SO MAYBE I WILL, INSTEAD, INVEST
IN A RANCH OR IN PAINTINGS OR
THINGS THAT DON'T BUILD JOBS
THAT CREATE A STRONGER ECONOMY.
THAT KIND OF DISTORTION OF OUR
ECONOMIC SYSTEM IS A BAD IDEA
FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY COUNTRY
WE DEPEND UPON PEOPLE OF MEANS
TO INVEST IN ENTERPRISES AND
STOCK MARKET.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE STOCK MARKET KEEPS GOING UP
WHICH IS GOOD FOR ALL OF US.
THE IDEA THAT THERE IS SOMEBODY
OUT THERE GIVE US UP FOR FREE IS
JUST NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> LOOKING BACK AT THE
ALTERNATIVE MINIMUM TAX THE ANT
WHEN IT WAS FIRST CREATED IT WAS
GOING AFTER A VERY SMALL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AND OVER THE YEARS IT
EXPANDED.
TO ROUGHLY 5 MILLION PEOPLE
UNDER AMT, IS THAT WHAT YOU SEE
POTENTIALLY HAPPENING HERE?
>> WELL, THAT'S, OF COURSE, ONE
CONCERN.
WHICH IS NOT ONLY WILL YOU
CONVINCE BILLIONAIRES NOT TO
INVEST AS MUCH AS THEY HAVE IN
THE PAST BUSINESSES OR STARTING
INVESTMENTS IN THE STOCK MARKET,
BUT INSTEAD YOU WILL HAVE MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE THAT GET HIT
WITH A TAX.
THE IDEA OF TAXING PEOPLE AS THE
VALUE OF SOMETHING GOES UP, NOT
WHEN THEY SELL IT, BUT JUST WHEN
THE VALUE GOES UP, THAT'S A
PRETTY DRAMATIC CHANGE.
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FROM
THAT KIND OF CHANGE I DON'T KNOW
IF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THOUGHT
THROUGH.
AND WHETHER IT APPLIES TO 700
BILLIONAIRES OR 700,000
AMERICANS, ULTIMATELY, THE IDEA
OF TAXING PEOPLE BASED ON THE
VALUE OF SOMETHING GOING UP
SUGGESTS VALUES WILL KEEP GOING
UP.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY GO DOWN?
ARE THEY GOING TO GET A REFUND
CHECK?
ARE THEY GOING TO GET PAID
INTEREST FOR NOT HAVING HAD THE
BENEFIT OF THEIR MONEY DURING
THE TIME WHEN THEY WERE TAXED
WHEN IT WENT UP BEFORE?
THERE ARE SO MANY PROBLEMS WITH
A DRAMATICALLY NEW TAX SCHEME
THAT I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE THOUGHT THROUGH.
I THINK IT'S A BIG MISTAKE.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE RECOGNIZE
THAT WITH NATURE EVERYTHING IS
CONNECTED.
AND THAT IF YOU CHANGE SOME
PORTION OF OUR NATURAL SYSTEM,
WHY IT COULD HAVE AN IMPACT
THROUGHOUT OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
WELL, THE SAME IS TRUE IN THE
ECONOMY.
WHEN YOU CHANGE DRAMATIC AN
ASPECT OF HOW WE TAX PEOPLE YOU
CAN EXPECT A LOT OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES NEW TAX IDEA --
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT KEEPS ON
SAYING THIS IS NOT GOING TO ADD
A SINGLE DOLLAR TO THE NATIONAL
DEBT AND THIS IS ALL GOING TO BE
PAID FOR.
EVEN THOUGH THE PAID FORS HAVE
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY IN THE PAST
FEW DAYS.
YOU DO A LOT OF REACHING ACROSS
THE AISLE TALKING TO DEMOCRATS.
DO YOU THINK MODERATE DEMOCRATS
LIKE THE SENATORS MARK WARNER,
LIKE THE MAGGIE HASANS, LIKE
OTHER SENATORS ARE GOING TO GO
FOR THIS KIND OF BIG CHANGE ON
THIS ISSUE?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY LOOK AND
SEE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS IN
TROUBLE THEY SEE DEMOCRATS ARE
IN TROUBLE POLITICALLY.
THEY WANT TO NEW TAX SYSTEM OF
SOME KIND SO THEY CAN IF YOU
WILL HOLD FAST TO THEIR ORIGINAL
COMMITMENT.
I THINK THEY ARE MAKING A
MISTAKE TO RAISE TAXES.
I THINK THEY ARE MAKING A BIG
MISTAKE TO PUT IN PLACE A NEW
TAX SCHEME.
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY.
AND, I ALSO THINK THEY ARE
SPENDING MONEY IN THE WRONG
WAYS.
LOOK, THEY ARE ADDING TO
INFLATION.
AND INSTEAD OF DEALING WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THE EMERGENCE OF
CHINA AS A GLOBAL COMPETITOR, WE
ARE GOING TO BE GIVING OUT TWO
YEARS OF FREE PRE-K.
RAISING TAXES AT A TIME WE
SHOULDN'T AND ALSO ENCOURAGING
MORE INFLATION AND NOT
ADDRESSING THE REAL PROBLEMS
THAT OUR COUNTRY FACES AND THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT
OBAMA WENT AFTER YOU AS A
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE IN 2012 ON
THIS ISSUE OF TAXES THAT YOU
WERE PAYING LESS AS A NURSE OR
SECRETARY.
AND IT IS THE SAME A MESSAGING
THAT THEY ARE USING TODAY.
HERE IS SENATOR DICK DURBIN.
>> BUT YOU OUGHT TO PAY SOME
TAXES.
IF YOU CAN BUILD ROCKETS AND
TAKE YOUR FRIENDS UP FOR A
LITTLE SHOT INTO SPACE,
SHOULDN'T YOU PAY A FEW BUCKS IN
TAXES?
I DON'T THINK IT'S UNREAM.
UNUNREASONABLE.
SAME THING TRUE FOR
CORPORATIONS.
LOOK AT THE MOST PROFITABLE
CORPORATIONS IN AMERICA TOO DARN
MANY OF THEM PAY NO TAXES.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> Bret: IS THAT ATTRACTIVE
POLITICALLY, SENATOR.
>> OBVIOUSLY BEEN WORKING FOR
THE DEMOCRATS FOR A LONG TIME
IT'S SIMPLY JUST NOT TRUE WHICH
IS THAT PEOPLE PAY TAXES AND THE
HIGHER INCOME PEOPLE IN AMERICA
AS YOU KNOW PAY A HIGHER SHARE
OF THEIR INCOME IN TAXES AS THEY
SHOULD.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE ARE ONE
OF THE MOST PROGRESSIVE, MEANING
ONE OF THE MOST HIGHLY TAXED
HIGH INCOME PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
PLUNGE DEVELOPED NATIONS.
CORPORATIONS PAY TAXES ON
INCOME.
FOLLOW THE RULES AND REPORT THE
INCOME CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
RULES AND PAY TAXES IF THEY HAVE
A PROFIT.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A PROFIT,
THEY DON'T HAVE A TAX.
SO, THESE ARE OBVIOUSLY
DIVERSIONARY THINGS AND THE
REALITY IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE.
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE GETTING
AROUND THE LAW SOMEHOW, THERE IS
A LOOPHOLE, FIX THE LOOPHOLE,
BUT DON'T CREATE A NEW TAX WHICH
IS GOING TO ENCOURAGE HIGH
INCOME PEOPLE NOT TO INVEST IN
STARTING BUSINESSES NOT TO
INVEST IN THE STOCK MARKET AND
CREATE MORE JOBS HERE.
THAT'S A SERIOUS MISTAKE.
>> Bret: I WANT TO READ TWEETS
FROM LARRY SUMMERS OBVIOUSLY
PROMINENT DEMOCRAT IN SEVERAL
DREARGSES TALKING ABOUT
INFLATION.
WHEN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
INFLATED BUDGET IN FEBRUARY IT
EXPECTED 2% INFLATION IN 2021.
I WAS WARNING ABOUT INFLATION.
THEIR FORECAST IS NO LOCKER
OPERATIVE.
MAY AND JUNE SECRETARY YELLEN
EXPRESSED CONFIDENCE IT WOULD BE
LATE BY 2021, EARLY 2022.
NOW THIS FORECAST IS NO LONGER
OPERATIVE.
HE GOES ON TO SAY IN THE
INTERVIEW SECRETARY YELLEN
ASSERTS TWICE THAT INFLATION HAS
DECELERATE.  THIS IS A BIT
MISLEADING.
AS THE TREE MONTH AND 12 MONTH
CPI INFLATION RATES ARE BOTH
AROUND 5% ON ANNUAL BASIS.
DEMOCRAT LARRY SUMMERS.
FINALLY YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
INFLATION AND WHERE WE ARE ON
THAT ISSUE?
>> I THINK IT'S HARD TO PREDICT
WHAT INFLATION IS GOING TO DO IN
THE FUTURE.
WE ARE SEEING IT NOW, PEOPLE ARE
SEEING IT IN THE PRICES THEY PAY
FOR FOOD AND GASOLINE.
BUT $1.9 TRILLION THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PUT OUT IN
JANUARY.
NOW ASKING FOR TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MORE I HOPE YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT A TRILLION IS.
A MILLION SECONDS AGO IT WAS
EARLY OCTOBER.
A BILLION SECONDS AGO GEORGE
HENTON WALKER BUSH WAS PRESIDENT
A TRILLION SECONDS AGO.
A TRILLION SECONDS AGO
NEANDERTHALS WALKED THE EARTH.
TRILLION IS ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
CREATING INFLATI